大家好,我是齐悟邱墨,跟大家做这个期货5分钟短线交易系统的分享的话,也想听有一个月的时间来。
那么在这一个月时间里面的话,也受到了不少这个粉丝的这个关注。
那么其中有一些粉丝呢,就是让我能够在这个日内交易这一块呢,能够再讲一讲。
那么在接下来的几节课里面的话,我就会对这个日内交易这一块做一些简单的这种交流吧。
希望能够给大家一些帮助还有启发。
那么其实关于这个日内交易的话,那可能我们有一些人呢,就是在这个日内交易上的一个理解呢,可能会有一些偏差。
那其实那个偏差的多数情况就是关于这个中午到底要不要持仓过中午的一个问题。
那其实呢,就是说我所理解的这个日内交易,这里就跟大家坦述清楚一下。
我自己所理解的这个日内交易呢,基本上就是在这个下午三点钟收盘到夜盘这一段时间是不持仓的。
那么晚上十一点钟之后也是不持仓的。
到第二天早上这一段时间也是不持仓的。
那么这个就是我们所说的这个日内交易。
那么关于这个中午到底要不要平仓啊,这个看个人的一个封控的要求吧。
呃,如果呃,当时呢,就是一般情况下就是中午啊,中午好一般情况下我都是我都会选择这个持仓过中午。
但是有时候呢,在这个风险因素比较大的情况下这个外盘波动比较大的情况下呢,你们我们可能就要做做好这个封控的一些。
一些要求,那你比如像上周五对吧,那可能我这个相交,呃,本来上午呢,可能有几百点的这个收益。
但是到了下午呢,一开盘就离开四五百点,那么瞬间你这个是瞬间你的福音啊,就变成了。
呃,就变成了这个付亏啊,那么这个是很寓门的事情。
所以说有时候那风险于素呢,是决定你要不要做这个中午持仓的一个一个考虑啊。
那多数时候呢,我们风险啊,那多数时候呢,这些是对这个中午的影响是不大的啊。
那么可能更大的就是在这个晚上还有这个下午盘收拾之后的一段时间啊。
下午收拾是因为外盘呢,就可能刚好属于这种开盘的时间段啊。
那么夜盘呢,属于他们那个交易伙业段。
虽然这两个时间段呢,可能就是不持仓啊的风险的规避可能会更好一点点。
呃,那么日内交易的话,他就是用这种比较小的这个规避啊,就是控制比较小的规避啊。
能够啊,就是日内交易能够更好地做好这个风控的一个管理啊。
那么规小,规避呢,可能会尽量的小。
那么收益你这个做的好了,日内的收益马上能够兑现,尤其是一种大波段的,大波震荡的情况现在可能你多空都有人做到。
那么可能你收益呢,就是会很好。
但是如果你做趋势的那可能,你啊,今天可能多头转了一点,那像我如果你没有及时的这个子营,那么你效率又变成了这个啊,就白开心,瞎开心。
所以说,做日内交易呢,他好就好,就把收益的及时的锁定锁定住啊。
呃,那么日内交易的好处呢,这个好处跟不好的地方呢,其实这个大家都能够理解,大家都能够理解。
呃,那基本上来讲呢,就好处他就是能够及时的这个把这个应亏兑现啊,能够实现这个风险的可控性。
呃,不好的地方就对你这个盯盘的压力啊,盯盘的压力会比较大啊,精神消耗比较大。
所以呢,我自己喜欢用一句话来形容这个日内交易。
就是说,我日内交易可以实现这个收益期限的这个平滑增长,但是呢,人会老的特别快。
呃,我不知道他就有没有发现啊,就是做交易久了,尤其是说日内交易久了,这个人啊,这个精神状态啊,其实会比较差,而且显得比较苍老。
呃,包括我自己一样,我都觉得自己都会显得比较老了,可能是经常盯着这个电脑屏幕的一个问题吧。
呃,那么有,呃,如果说日内交易,如果你确实想做日内交易,又不怕老的情况下呢?
那,那就,那就做日内交易吧,但是你要做好这个,啊,这个日内交易,你这个精神损耗大,那可能比较容易老的这种情况,你要考虑一下。
呃,那其实另外一个呢,就是做日内交易呢,大家可能也会比较关,关注这个频率的一个问题。
呃,那可能大家都会,多多少少都会看到一些文章,尤其是一些高手的一些分享的一些经验分享吧。
可能都会提到这个日内交易的一个频率的问题。
呃,那么多数的这些人呢,他们做的成功呢,多数都是因为做这个低频的这个日内交易啊。
啊,高频或者草单的这种呢,啊,肯定也有人做。
但是呢,觉得大多数人呢,缺乏这方面的一些,呃,呃,经验吧。
呃,或者是对于这种草单和高频这种呢,他对于天赋要求都会比较高。
那多数人呢,可能都还是比较适合一做这个低频的这个日内交易。
呃,我,我所,我所做的,我目前做的,我也是基本上是做这个低频的,啊。
一天可能就是商务会合,啊,就是商务次这个交易啊,不多,啊。
那有时候呢,呃,有时候呢,因为行情属于真当的情况下呢,可能我们这个交易的这个频率呢,就会被迫啊,变得多一点点。
啊,但也不会说多的特别多,可能有个七八次啊,十来次啊,二十次已经到点,到顶了,二十次已经到顶了。
那这个音乐室这个行情确实就是小幅动里面不停的震荡,那么你可能下的单冲了,哎,啊,突然又得去去平仓啊,去执手或者指引啊。
好,这个就是跟这个行情也有关系。
呃,但是呢,根本的情况呢,就是怎么样的,就是我们做日内交易。
呃,你做的越多呢,可能就会出的越多啊,出的越多,说呢,其实呢,啊,尽量的扫交易呢,是对于我们来讲的就是避免这种。
太多的犯错啊,那么你每次犯错,犯错呢,那可能都是以止损啊,都是以止损为结果,那么你过多的。
呃,止损呢,那么可能对于你自己的一个本金,那么可能不是特别的啊,好,而且的话,过多的止损呢,也会影响到你这个交易的形态,形态。
因为日内交易呢,其实跟你的情绪也有很大的关系,有时候呢,日内交易的时候呢,啊,说的次数比较多的时候呢,你就会来情绪了,来情绪之后呢,你就会变得比较有赌信了,啊,一等你的赌信一上来的话,那么你日内交易呢,就会出现很大的一个。
呃,亏损啊,这个就经常是做日内交易的最大的一个机会,啊,呃,现在会出于这么一个情况,所以呢,我们很害怕的就是,如果日内交易的时候做到这个情绪一起来的时候呢,就把这个日内交易做成了这个隔夜啦,或者甚至做成了长夜,为什么呢?
因为你这个被套了,被套了,你不想,啊,不想直损,啊,不想去输掉这部分的钱,啊,所以你就,啊,就放弃了这个日内交易的一个原则,啊,不辞昌,啊,隔,隔夜,啊,就是不辞昌过下午,啊,下午,啊,不辞昌过这个,啊,下午,或者是,啊,不辞昌到晚上,或者不辞昌到第二天早上,啊,然后你就会放弃你这个基本上的原则,啊,那基本上大错。
啊,就在说难免了,呃,那么其实关于这个日内交易的话,呃,基本上就是先简单的跟大家啊,聊这些内容,呃,那么接下来的,接下来呢,就可能就会跟大家具体的聊一聊啊,怎么去做这个日内交易啊,会更好,也在这个交易的频率上控制啊,在交易的一个出入场点啊,那么都会跟大家,啊,在后面的课程里面会详续的介绍。
呃,如果大家对一个日内交易有兴趣的话,可以继续关注,呃,那么我们下一节课再见,谢谢大家。